what we do is we try to make sure that
we so over deliver in value you can use
the free stuff it's better than most
people's paid stuff but the paid stuff
we want it to be excellent excellent
production values excellent content 10x
100x the value you paid for it if you
have that you have no problem
Carrie welcome back to the think media
podcast so good to be here man I
appreciate you so much Sean I'm excited
to get into the topic today
um you are very prolific and you have
packaged what you know into products and
programs and it's helped you build
really a big business uh impactful
business that helps church leaders
leaders overall you not just have built
a very powerful podcast with a huge
listenership helping leaders in the
business world and in the church world
but you've also created online courses
you've written multiple best-selling
books and I want to learn from you the
process of packaging what you know a lot
of our community wants to create an
online course they may want to write an
ebook or a full-on physical book
traditional published maybe and and
really reach more people and then of
course they're trying to figure out how
do I package what I know in a way that
is actually effective it's one thing to
just commit to making an online course
it's another thing to making a good
online course maybe creating a framework
around things and you're a very studied
and red leader yourself so I kind of
just want to unpack how you go through
this process of packaging what you know
and then marketing it and monetizing it
and so let's start off with what are
your existing products and programs and
what formats are they in just kind of as
a quick rundown yeah sure so it's
changed a lot over the years it started
as a hobby a decade ago and become
something totally different but right
now freeze frame in this moment
sort of the centerpiece of what we do is
something we launched
um like not even a year ago called The
Art of leadership academy and what it is
it's a place mostly for church leaders
and also faith-minded Business Leaders
to come together it's a membership
program so it costs right now 447
dollars a year to join all of my premium
content is is inside the academy so
that's all of my courses I think I have
a half dozen of them I do some coaching
in there so like this only with uh the
people who want to join us for that
month once a month and that's available
to all Academy members and then I do
something called monthly team training
which is like a short course 15 minutes
just a video you can play because a lot
of people don't develop their teams
particularly well it's like oh I gotta
teach on something so you whip it off
the night before so we'll prep for that
and then just create some short content
with an application guide and then the
best part the secret sauce has been we
built out this like Social Media Forum a
private one just in the academy where
there's some really cool sharing
opportunities threads conversation
dialogue Community happening between the
1500 church leaders who are in it
already and that's sort of the the
center piece of that and then I do a
leadership podcast and it's growing
really well right now and then I also
blog on my website we have some free
articles and that's sort of the heart of
it it's writing podcasting and then the
art of leadership academy I think that
covers most of what I do and then I'm
still a speaker so I've written five
books but books tend to be episodic
that's about every couple of years you
put out a book or so but I do yeah
probably 20 to 25 events a year Max less
than I used to and those are for church
leaders or Business Leaders I'll just go
out and communicate usually around one
of my biggest blog topics or something I
wrote in a book more recently
so today and this is amazing you have
the art of leadership academy and
there's six courses in that it did you
make those courses though over the past
few years yes so we started by just
offering courses a la carte
um you know you got into you asked a
question about monetization and honestly
I had no monetization plans at all when
I started this this was a hobby I
thought I would start writing three days
a week you know just put something on
the blog and it was the golden days of
2012 and SEO isn't wasn't then what it
is now which is highly Technical and you
publish a post on Church growth and
pastors find it and we had immediate
success but there was no monetization
behind it then I started a leadership
podcast just because I really enjoyed
doing it cost of Entry is super low so
in 2014 I launched a leadership podcast
just to bring the back room
conversations I was having
um to people I cared about my staff my
team other leaders I'm like wow I'm
privileged to have amazing conversations
with great people let's bring that to
the public for free so I'm still doing
that but again no monetization strategy
I mean I probably could be a lot
wealthier than I am but you know I just
that wasn't my motivation and then
eventually what happens is I got a lot
of inbound you know at first it's just
you and a keyboard and a couple of
comments here and there in a few emails
and then when millions of people showed
up it was like oh inbound inbound so I
started to have to hire and uh that's
when we started accepting partners for
the podcast I'm still really picky we
just had a meeting this week there we've
left a lot of money on the table like if
you're a sponsor on my podcast I believe
in you I believe in your company and I
want leaders I always feel my brand is
Trust
so as soon as you buy the academy if you
click on a sponsor Link in the podcast
if you click on an affiliate link on my
website I don't want that just to be a
revenue thing for me I want it to be
value added for you and there have been
people that we dropped so but I started
doing that on the podcast and then I
wanted to get into online courses
because I would be asked for Consulting
we end up saying no 90 of the time when
people ask me to appear in person and
I'm like well I can go deeper than a
blog post deeper than a podcast and just
producing an online course so we started
those maybe five years ago so I probably
produced one or two a year about six or
there might be seven in there I haven't
counted lately and then earlier this
year uh in early 2022 we bundled it all
together in the art of leadership
academy and here's the crazy part we
used to sell a single course for 447
dollars now you get all of them for a
447 dollar annual membership so it was a
big risk but we're really really
encouraged by the early results in that
and best of all the dialogue in the
community in the art of leadership
academy has been exceptional just great
I love it so take me back then to the
first course and thinking about the
listener so someone's like okay
I want to create an online course and
I'm trying to figure out
what to make it about but I'm also
trying to figure out how to structure it
how to organize it for you how did you
get what was your first ever course how
long was it and how did you go about
actually assembling it was there
anything you studied you have a
background in teaching
as a pastor so maybe that maybe comes a
little bit naturally to walk me through
the process of any insecurities or
learnings of getting the first one off
the ground and if you remember what it
was called yeah you know I'm kind of
entrepreneurial so I don't remember
studying the art of making an online
course I just kind of did one and I
hadn't taken a whole lot myself which is
silly but I just I felt like I was
responding to the number one question I
was being asked so the first course was
called the high impact leader which over
the years evolved into what is now at
your best a book you know very well and
um it's a book it's now a course it's
inside the academy Etc but it started
out of a talk I gave a productivity talk
in 2015 maybe at Mark batterson's
National Community Church in Washington
DC
and I was trying out new content because
by that point I was leaving a church
full time you know my family was fairly
healthy uh I was blogging three times a
week I had a leadership podcast and the
number one question I was being asked is
how do you get it all done and what had
happened to me is almost a decade
earlier
I burned out and I spent years
reconstructing my life getting coaching
getting counseling and I created these
principles that helped me stay out of
burnout help me Thrive which eventually
are now and at your best so I hadn't
really shared that content people would
ask me that question and I'd be like
well you know you should think about how
you manage your energy not just how you
manage your time if you're a morning
person do your more but it was very blah
blah blah like all over there so for
this talk at National Community Church I
tried to organize it and that took me
days like I'm like okay well what are
the principles like I never I knew what
they were internally but I didn't know
how to express them it's like you know
somebody's saying to you how did you
build think media well you kind of know
but do you really know
like that would take a lot of work for
you to describe it step by step yeah it
was me and my phone and you know I
upload a video to YouTube and here's my
first video but like that's a that's a
different thing so I spent the time put
it into a 45 minute talk and delivered
it for Mark Batterson and Mark stood up
when I was finished he he intercepted me
as I was sitting back down in my seat he
goes that needs to be a book well I had
just released a book and I had other
priorities so I'm like well maybe not a
book but maybe I could do a course so I
thought short nine sessions less than 10
minutes each I had a partner at the time
in Orange the rethink group flew down to
Atlanta they had the studios and
everything I recorded it I you know it
took me a month or so to prep not of
like 40 hours a week but just working on
it I refined my ideas and and the filter
that I used was I assume people have
short attention span I'd never done an
online course before and the filter I
used was helpful how is this helpful
like people care less about my story
they can care more about their story so
if I can produce some principles that
will work in the lives of other people
that I could field test then that might
be a good course so I wrote it with that
in mind and you know it wasn't as
polished as I didn't have the green zone
yellow zone Red Zone stuff I hadn't at
your best I didn't have all the handles
around it
but we released it and uh it took off
and the craziest thing of all if you
want to talk about pricing man like that
product had a four-year shelf life we
took it off the shelf I think we
launched it in 2017 2016. pulled it off
in 2021 when at your best released and I
believe I launched it at 59 and I just
couldn't imagine anyone paying 59 at
that point because this was 2016. it was
online and on a thumb drive do you
remember those yeah you produce thumb
drive so we actually had like almost
physical digital copies of it and we had
a little workbook that that I had
produced for it just like 60 Pages or so
59 I thought nobody will buy this anyway
it's sold out
and then we cut off sales and then we
released it again and we raised the
price to 79 and nobody boxed and then
99. well when we took it off the market
I think it was
397 dollars nothing changed in that
course nothing it was the same product
but it went from 59 to 397 dollars and
that was another big decision for me I
mean every Black Friday everybody
discounts whatever they do I've never
had a sale what I try to do is I try to
price everything I do according to Value
because I really believe if you get
really good value you will never
complain so uh I tried to think okay how
much is you getting and you just went
through at your best at our best with
your whole company you know what our
evenings at home with your wife and
children worth fifty nine dollars 397
dollars what is getting a thousand
productive hours of your life back this
year compared to the old system and by
the time we released the book at your
best in the course at your best I had
thousands of data points and stories
from people who had done this and I
found out these principles work almost
universally so I could start to make
brand promises like what would you what
would you pay if you're a preacher to
have your sermon done on Tuesday rather
than on Saturday night how much is that
worth to you how much is it worth to you
as a business owner not to burn out and
to do less and accomplish more it's got
to be worse than three more than 397
dollars or now 447 dollars so as long as
there's a value gap between what you get
from a product and what you paid from a
product and that actually works in favor
of the customer you never have to put
stuff on sale because as Seth Godin says
once you do it on sale it's a race to
the bottom because somebody will always
like if you're competing on price
somebody will always do it cheaper
somebody will always do it less than you
so what I want to do is I want to have
super high value the other thing on
pricing that we've done we've always
offered it 30 day no questions asked
money back guarantee and our refund rate
I don't know what you see in this space
but for software as a service or online
courses the refund rate is usually
through the roof like 30 percent or more
ours is between one and three percent
depending on the product because what we
do we give away we want our free stuff
to be better than most people's paid
stuff so you can find a lot of the
principles on my blog for free that made
it into at your best now you're not
going to get a course with me teaching
you through 14 sessions the new course
is 14 sessions you're not going to get
the convenience of a 55 000 word book
where every word has been edited and
thought through but you can find it for
free if you've got a few days more power
to you go do it but what we do is we try
to make sure that we so over deliver in
value you can use the free stuff it's
better than most people's paid stuff but
the paid stuff we want it to be
excellent excellent production values
excellent content 10x 100x the value you
paid for it if you have that you have no
problem so to me it's a lot more
complicated people are like what's your
next course going to be when I feel
myself or collaborator has something
that that we can deliver that is going
to help the person and they will get 10
times minimum the value out of it then
they paid for it then I'm ready to do
the next product that was a master class
with a lot of nuggets that I want to
recap a few and I want to invite you to
add any new nuances into some things I
heard that I really believe is a
framework for The Listener that wants to
create an online course number one you
responded to the number one question you
get the most I think for listeners as
you're posting content and as a footnote
to your content Empire you do have a
podcast you started in 2014 but it is
also a video podcast meaning your
YouTube channel and uh your not just
getting great results now but that
continues to grow so you're Distributing
content you're Distributing your blogs
and and as you're adding a lot of free
content up front which many people are
doing you eventually develop even a
small audience that starts to ask you a
consistent question and that what should
I make my online course about the number
one question you get the most probably
for us it's like how do I start and grow
a YouTube channel that makes money and
our main YouTube course answers that
question you then also number two did
raw first
it was also somebody that asked you to
talk on this you had heard it elsewhere
so you did a version of it first I've
learned that to be true in my own story
where
you can actually develop your online
course might be it will probably be
cultivated in public you'll probably
practice in public for a speaker or
Pastor it may be many speaker many
pastors have turned a sermon series into
a book they've turned a sermon series
into something else because it resonated
so I think the cool thing about
committing to creating YouTube videos
weekly podcast weekly is you are testing
messages in public and sometimes seeing
what resonates so you went raw first
then you did a refined version
but what's amazing is you fast forward
to today and you've done a further
refined version and then what you did
step five was you've also refined your
marketing because as you continue to
impact people along the way you got more
case studies more feedback more nuances
okay this actually leads to imagine your
sermons done by Tuesday this actually
leads to imagine you have a thousand
hours because you essentially you've
been getting custom testimonials in the
process and I can relate to a lot of
these steps because video ranking
Academy is actually now six years old
we've redone it multiple times it
responded to that question there was a
raw version there was a refined version
there's been a further refined version
and
kind of put a cherry on the top of the
whole thing your book at your best is so
incredible and I've told you that before
not just the content itself but actually
it's just one of the great books ever
written that's a big statement but just
it's just it reads well it's amazing it
doesn't surprise me because you talked
about how much editing how much pain
love had gone into it the Frameworks are
strong the stories are strong it's not
too long it's kind of like Albert
Einstein said I think that if you can't
explain it simply you don't understand
it well enough well this shouldn't be a
surprise to us because you can take this
all the way back to responding to a
question raw version refined version
further refined version living it
testing it doing it over and over and
then once you bring it all the way to
book form it's kind of a painful process
for The Listener that's like I want to
write a book in the next three months as
opposed and you may be ready but in case
of a truly kind of viral message that I
think you have here that's also a pretty
annual seller that'll keep impacting it
speaks to just actually The Continuous
refinement of one other Nuance I noticed
which is kind of developing a core
message
kind of finding what is that genius Zone
something that you've refined in your
own life how to be at your best how to
be a high impact leader how to recover
from burnout which is now we're talking
really the the Legacy piece of this is
you could argue that a decade or decades
have gone into the message because you
you experience the pain yourself you
pursued Solutions you tested a lot of
hypothesis and disproved them you found
the things that worked and now fast
forward to today you've packaged it but
then repackaged it and there's also been
an evolution in price along the way I
said a lot so for you to to poke holes
in any of the nuances there but to me I
see that as kind of a framework for
someone listening that wants to make a
truly impactful online course don't
overthink it at the start because it was
you were invited to a talk the talk
turned into the original package he got
it to the market it was it was 59 get it
out there have something that resonated
but then you've also refined it along
the way and not only did the price
eventually for the course Elevate now
it's in the uh you know art of
leadership academy but now it's a book
that's also impacting at a crazy level a
lot of steps have been there on the
journey any feedback on my assessment of
that process I think it's very accurate
and I think you know there's a couple
things that we haven't touched on yet
your pain is probably related to your
purpose so if you had to look at what
weaves all of my content together well
first of all
I wasn't you know a quote influencer I
wasn't a thought leader in my 20s I was
in school and then in my 30s I started
leading a church in my 40s I led a
church when I was 50. I handed it off to
the Next Generation and started to focus
more on the stuff I'm doing now but the
stuff I'm doing now arose from like I'm
also a law school grad so the short way
to understand it is I went to law school
but nobody taught me how to run a law
firm and I went to Seminary and no one
taught me how to run a church so if you
want to look at carinuhoff.com what my
company does
I show you everything you didn't learn
and you're figuring out the hard way and
I can give you shortcuts that's kind of
what you do right like you've figured
out with think media oh this is you know
this is the camera to buy you don't have
to go and order 17 kits and try it out
yourself you can listen to my
recommendations and so I've figured out
like what do you do with a toxic team
member I've got one called The Art of
team leadership that's one of the
courses in the academy and honestly I
just made so many Miss pardon me
mistakes in leadership that I wrote A
Course about it it's like oh when you
get toxic people here's what to do with
it here's how to govern remote work etc
etc so it's sort of that
that thing where if your pain whatever
that happened to be will probably lead
you somehow to your purpose and that
burnout
most painful thing I've ever been
through and the Reconstruction like when
I was doing that reconstruction I wasn't
thinking one day this is going to be a
course that's going to sell thousands of
courses and you know a book that's going
to help tens of thousands of leaders
like that was the furthest thing from my
mind it's like how do I get to tomorrow
but I took good notes and then those
notes eventually led to a question I did
another course called The Art of online
influence because by last year the
number one question I was getting then
wasn't how do you get it all done
because they had read my stuff or read
the book or taken the course it was how
do you grow this company man how did you
get you know 26 million downloads on
your podcast how did that happen and how
did you build such a big influential
following and of course it was an
accident because I wasn't trying to
build a company I was trying to help
people and find a a hobby that would
keep me out of jail so it was writing at
5am before my 8 A.M job it was like yeah
I'll just write some stuff it's fun and
of course now that's not a hobby anymore
it's what I do full time so I had to
find some other Hobbies but you know it
was the art of online influence because
wherever I went whether I was having
lunch with Business Leaders or church
leaders they'd always pull me aside and
listen for the hush tone
because when they go okay Sean that was
really nice but um
how did you build think media how did
that they'll talk in a different tone of
voice because they really want to know
the secret and of course it's never a
single line but if you start to really
think about that okay well how did we
build influence on the internet well I
always talked about less my story and
more
The Listener story or the reader's story
you know I I have a formula for
podcasting which is if I talk more than
10 of the time I'm a failure that that I
have to let the guests shine and that I
have to you know follow the Curiosity
Trail because I often Hear Carrie I
really love the way you interview people
and I hear this on a regular basis so I
sat down and I thought okay how do I do
my interview
and then I enumerated you know some 500
episodes in
okay good interviews I do this bad
interviews I do this so don't do that
try this and I'm very happy to let the
guests take the spotlight because I get
to talk on my blog I get to talk in my
courses I get to talk if I preach but
it's like my job there is to listen to
be curious and pull things out of the
guests that other people don't do it and
here's how you do that so that's a whole
unit in the art of online influence so
that's how I develop my content it's
just like I had a big problem this
summer where I ran into a vision crisis
so my next course might be the art of
casting vision
why because I went through three months
of pain trying to go I've lost my way
here in this company and I gotta find
that out and I read books and I listened
to podcasts and I researched it and I
talked to friends and then we found a
Crystal Clear Vision my team is excited
I'm excited we're moving into the future
but then I thought back on all the times
I lost Vision over the last 20 years and
what happened and what were the
conditions and I took I got pages of
notes and now I'll do more research but
that'll probably be the next course it's
beautiful now
can you go through your process in what
you think makes
communication compelling specifically
when you're trying to teach
um how to be a high impact leader if
your next course is going to be the art
of of casting Vision or the art of
vision when you're assembling a course
what have you learned with a background
now as a prolific podcast Communicator
as also having to make sermons uh weekly
is challenging and you you communicate
in multiple different modalities you
could Let's either start with the
mistakes you think that communicators
are are hurting them that make lose
attention in a video or a podcast makes
a podcast boring or social media or or
what you think it Powers it up what are
what is any kind of Frameworks you have
so that when you present you record one
video inside of your members area how
are you structuring that so the way I
think about it is Clarity Clarity
Clarity Clarity it's that uh Einstein
quote it's like you have to understand
it well enough to be able to explain it
to somebody in kindergarten and where a
lot of content goes wrong is the
communicator doesn't understand it well
enough to be able to explain it and
teach it at a level where the
uninitiated can understand and so what I
work on in my communication I don't
always get it right but what I work on
is I think about the bones of a talk or
the bones like what are what are the
principles for Session One the
principles if you're doing a 40-minute
message right I spoke to a couple of of
leaders in Virginia and Toronto last
week and what did I do well first the
first thing I'm trying to do in the
first few minutes is establish a
connection with my audience and I don't
do that by talking about me I start that
as you teach by talking about them and
I'll I'll ask them a really intriguing
question like why is it that so many
leaders end up collapsing morally it's
true in politics it's true in business
but you know what's awful it's really
true in the church boom well most people
are hooked at that point and then it's
like well could that happen to you could
that happen to me blah blah blah so you
you do some kind of hook to start with
and what you're trying to surface is
either a really interesting problem and
in particular a problem that they're
struggling with or interested enough to
you know take on for themselves or how
many of you have experienced some form
of burnout in the last year quick show
of hands you know there might be more of
you than you even think let me tell you
why boom boom boom and then I can talk
about burnout for an hour and then you
want to be really clear on some of the
principles like you know we you were
just on my show and you quoted back one
of the lines from at your best my my you
know time management productivity book
and it's like if and I worked really
hard on this sentence but uh it goes
something like this uh if it's not if if
your busy season has no ending it's not
a busy season it's your life Well that
took hours and hours of me thinking
about going to parties and telling
people yeah I'm you seem really busy
yeah it's really busy it's really busy
you always say that and I'm like oh wait
a minute seasons of Beginnings seasons
have endings
if your season has no beginning and
ending your busy season isn't just a
season it's your life that's where that
Rhythm came out of but that is like if
you have a big funnel like all these
ideas swirling around boom boom the
problem with most preachers the problem
with most communicators the problem with
most video content creators is you get
lost in that sea of ideas and you
haven't done the reduction like what's a
really good pasta sauce I know you're
you're starting out as a gurmond now
Sean you're on your way
it's not you threw a bunch of stuff into
the pot and you served it 10 minutes
later it's that you let it reduce and
reduce and reduce and reduce until it
becomes really thick and really good and
the flavors kind of meld that's when a
sauce becomes amazing and that's what
you need to do in your communication and
that is the really hard work of taking
complicated ideas and expressing them
simply so and in a way that resonates
with people's experience so once I have
three four five six of those hooks you
know key key areas and I know like oh
this could be a six unit course idea one
idea two idea three idea four and in
communication Andy Stanley calls it this
I've learned so much from Andy Stanley
he says what's your bottom line so your
bottom line
is time off won't heal you when the
problem is how you spend time on you
know I got a whole section on why
vacations don't work because we've all
had that situation we took two weeks off
lay at the beach totally relaxed we come
back and we feel like we get hit by a
truck on Monday Morning by 11 A.M why is
that well the problem isn't the way you
vacation you know how to vacation but
time off won't heal you because the
problem is how you spend your time on
and what we need to plan is how do you
spend your time on so again that was
that was hours of thinking into me
trying to figure out why do so many
people come back from vacations and
sabbaticals and minutes after they get
back they feel like they never left and
it's like that was it it just hit me one
day I wrote it down and then I had to
figure out how do I express it in a
sentence that is memorable so it's a
hook so that people can take it with
them so you want to have one for all of
even if you're doing a short on YouTube
you want to have a hook like like that
that you know on my burnout thing if you
don't take the Sabbath the Sabbath will
take you or um leaders who never take a
break end up breaking do you hear how
that that kind of Rhymes as a phrase
again that's hours of work just thinking
noodling going for a bike ride or
whatever it's like that's it leaders who
never take a break end up breaking if
you don't take a Sabbath the Sabbath
will take you that's burnout it's
involuntary rest and then you write it
down and that becomes your hook but
those become memorable and when they're
memorable they become portable so you've
really got to work on Clarity of
thinking
and that's hard work and it's not
googleable because people can tell did
you steal this off some motivational
poster from the 90s you know or did you
steal it off someone else's website with
a Google search or did that does that
content live in you and if it lives in
you you don't have to study you don't
have to memorize it I mean you'll learn
your bottom lines you'll learn the way
you know green zone yellow zone Red Zone
you'll learn phrases like that but
um my goodness it lives in you so it
just kind of flows out of you and people
can tell they can tell if you're faking
it they can tell if it's imposter
syndrome so what I would say is the work
you need to do is to look inside like
were you bullied as a kid you had some
material there uh did you fail in your
first couple attempts at at you know
content creation you probably have some
content there so that's where I would
look to the Past because those personal
Stories the pain of like having to let
go a toxic staff member
it's awful and all right well
I probably have some content there what
did I learn
[Music]
hey we're gonna get back into the
content in just a second but today's
episode is brought to you by tube 1K
challenge.com if you want to start or
grow a successful YouTube channel in
2023 then you're gonna love this free
five-day challenge hosted by me Sean
Cannell and the think media team we're
going to be sharing the best tactics and
strategies for getting views getting
subscribers and the best methods for
making money in a 2023 world even if you
have a small Channel we only do these
challenges a few times a year they are
completely free but you have to register
to be a part of the private group where
all of the streaming all of the
giveaways and all of the community and
connection happens inside of the tube 1K
challenge to register just go to tube
the number one k challenge.com the link
of course is in the show notes now let's
get back to the featured content
[Music]
if you were to Let's Workshop assuming
the art of leadership academy is not
where all of your courses live but you
were going to now knowing what you know
now after all your experience you're
going to
package and promote and launch this
Vision course break down over the next
couple months how you would do it
how many videos do you think it would be
where are you going to upload and host
that and maybe however you want to
approach this but if you were to just
put yourself in the viewer uh listeners
shoes that wants to get a course off the
ground how much margin would you give
yourself how would you keep yourself
motivated to again sit down outline
record upload
and and what are those steps in your
minds of just how you would do that
today if you wanted to launch kind of a
simple mini course and get it to Market
so that you could package what you know
impact people's lives but also start
generating Revenue specifically as a
content creator that's an educator
thought leader right that that an online
course is relevant for them how would
you do it I would give yourselves a long
Runway so back to the cooking metaphor
the best content comes out of a long
process to germinate the brand is a
really interesting thing so if you
started to say okay I'm going to write
my art of casting Vision course today
you're gonna have an empty Google doc
and you're going to start writing and
you'll definitely have something on the
page at noon maybe you'll have an
outline by five o'clock but it won't be
that good it's got to simmer and the way
you know from what I've the little bit
of brain research I've done
um there's Science Now behind this idea
that your best ideas hit you in the
shower or when you're running or when
you're not trying to think of ideas
what's happening is your brain is
working in the background to connect
disparate and isolated thoughts it's
helping you gain Clarity when you're not
working on Clarity so you're mowing the
lawn and for some reason the art of
casting Vision Pops in your mind and
you're like oh wait a minute that's it
and then grab your phone Grab Your Voice
Memos app grab Evernote whatever you use
your notes and write it down because
it's not coming back like write it down
in the moment I've got so many voice
memos I've got so much stuff in Evernote
where I'm just capturing so I actually
opened up an art of casting Vision file
that I've been working on since August
so this is like four months old I
probably won't record a course until the
spring so let's say it's now been
simmering in the background for eight
months but what I have here is field
notes what I've got is a little bit
about how I ran into that problem and
then I'll just can I give you an actual
example of what I wrote down that will
probably turn into session one of the
course yeah signs you to and this is
marketing language too signs you don't
have a white hot vision
you're delaying on key
subjects because you don't have Clarity
you can't make decisions your drive is
suffering you're just maybe your balance
but like you just haven't got that fire
in the belly
um your business or your organization or
you are moving in random directions
everything looks good you've got mood
swings one day you're super motivated
the next you're super lethargic and
you've got a lot of brain fog you can't
really see your way through it now I
might make I might change some of those
but like that's a really good start
because people are like all right do I
have a vision casting problem it's like
well here's some signs you actually
don't have a white hot Vision well
that's marketing language but it also
what what something like that does
because if you're giving a talk and I
preached for over 20 years so I'm used
to giving talks in front of a live
audience what you want to do in those
first five minutes or what you want to
do in that first 30 60 seconds of your
video is you want to pull everybody in
you want to find as many common touch
points as you can so you might say
Sean you might be like oh I have no
trouble making decisions but I'm like
yeah but do you find that you have mood
swings or you're a little lethargic or
one day you're super hot and the next
day you're kind of like I don't even
want to do this anymore or you've got
brain fog and you never used to have
brain fog you're like okay now I'm
hooked or you're like this is not for me
okay maybe it's not for you because if
you don't have a vision problem you
don't need this product I'm talking to
people who can do a better job doing
that so I've got those notes I've got
those field notes and then what I'm
going to do is I will sit down one day
months in advance of recording it or at
least a month in advance of recording it
and go that feels introductory because
my goal is to hook everybody in so that
we're all on the same page and they can
see how this applies some of them they
don't have a vision for the for work
some of them don't have a vision for
family some of them don't have a vision
for their life I've got a story in there
I interviewed ramit Sethi a personal
finance guy and he said what's your rich
life look like that question bugged me
for a month and I had a good answer on
the spot but I'm like more of the same
and more the same as in a vision that
will make it into the course but I wrote
that down because now five months later
I'm not going to remember that or I
might remember that by chance so then
I'm going to start organizing the
content and then I'm going to say well
what are the gaps and I'll probably do
some reading on casting Vision look at
some hbr our articles see what's out
there but again this is your content
you're not there to redo the hbr that's
Harvard Business Review they do that
better than I ever will so then
um you know I remember Arthur Brooks's
book from strength to strength learned
one thing from that then there's a Tim
Ferriss podcast I gleaned a great quote
from a guy named rule of bota I've got
that in here I'm like yeah I'm going to
talk about the size of the problem so
one of the units will be the size of the
problem what problem are you trying to
solve and then I'm going to talk about
that problem should be big it should be
inexhaustible and you shouldn't try be
able to solve it in the next few months
like if your vision is to grow by 20 you
might solve that by Q2 you know where we
landed as a team is our new vision is to
reverse the decline in the church
and when I share that with people it
gets an oof it gets a oh my gosh like
are you kidding do you know how big that
problem is exactly but we could work on
that for 20 years and it's going to be
bigger than us and we're going to need
partners and we're gonna need people to
help so you know what is your big
problem that you're trying to solve and
a lot of entrepreneurs they can't answer
that question and when you can't answer
that question you don't really have a
product and you don't really have a
message like what are you trying to do
are you trying to solve self-esteem
for young girls are you trying to solve
addiction issues are you trying to solve
growth problems with meteoric growth in
a company are you and it's got to be big
enough that you can't solve it by the
next quarter otherwise your vision isn't
going to be red hot I knew what it was
when I was at in a church because it was
so easy we had 300 000 people who
wouldn't be in church on a Sunday
morning within a 30 minute drive of our
church that's a pretty big problem we're
probably not going to solve that by next
weekend so that's going to give us
something to work on but you know and so
those are some excerpts so then I put
the bones in place it's like okay
session one and talk about signs that
you don't have a Clear Vision uh then
we're going to talk about step one is to
define the problem here's some exercises
then we're going to talk about how do
you relate that to a vision what's the
difference between a vision and a
mission and then we can talk about how
do you communicate that Vision how do
you explain it and then there's probably
another unit in there and then I'll
start to build those out and then you
know we'll get film crew and I'll have
all the content written in an Ideal
World I have the application guide done
because I already know what I want the
teams to do before I record the video
and then we'll just shoot and then we go
into marketing but if you've designed
the course well the marketing is already
baked in because you already know what
problem you're solving you already know
who it's for it's not like I created
this thing in an isolation you you
already know who it's for and you know
what their pain point is and what the
other thing I'll do is I'll test these
ideas out in the academy by asking
questions of the leaders we have there
and I'll test these ideas out on social
media and I might even do a real or a
short where I'm like hey if have you
ever suffered from these problems and
what's the issue or what big problem are
you trying to work on right now let me
know because then at minimum I'm going
to get examples or uh another thing you
can do I did this in the academy
recently I'm I'm doing the monthly
trainings we get a video shoot coming
and I'm like hey what do you wish I
would talk about
or what problem are you trying to solve
so get listener feedback and that will
inform it and if you've got the
combination of listener feedback and
some expertise in an area you
potentially have a product you certainly
have a subject maybe you have a product
wow so eight months simmer then organize
it then asking what are the gaps
researched some more then bones do you
consider the bones the outline like
writing outline so then outline it then
film it then also if possible create a
guide and a good online course comes
with a workbook essentially yeah yep and
then upload it what do you practically
use for your hosting at this point
so yeah my team is better at answering
that I believe it's learndash and mighty
networks so learndash is where our
courses live and all of our video
trainings
um that are the ones behind the paywall
and then
inside the academy and then the chat and
conversation and community
in the academy is hosted by Mighty
networks so they have two platforms one
is the mighty networks label we have the
white label version of Mighty Network so
when you go in looks exactly like we
would design our own custom Academy and
at the bottom is a little copyright
Mighty Network so we white labeled it
got it yeah and we our YouTube boot camp
Community is hosted in in Mighty
networks the white level version then
allows it to be they see the name of the
course essentially or they see the art
of leadership academy and it's yeah it's
like experiencing your brand with all of
your branding all of your graphics
um and then uh at this point and try to
go back to being in the shoes of someone
who's just starting and maybe that
doesn't have a team and probably doesn't
have a team do you think it's possible
to create shoot outline upload organized
landing page email list launch a course
completely by yourself
um I certainly uh couldn't do it by
myself and remember I was doing this as
I was developing a revenue model so I
had to go to Partnerships
um now you know I'm also in my 50s when
I'm doing this if I was 18 I would
probably be a lot better at that stuff
so I I'm I'm definitely the content 30
000 foot Vision Lane that's what I do
but at the time when we launched our
first course I had two assistants that
was it and they didn't really have the
technical skill either so we leaned into
people like Alejandro Reyes who helped
us market and launch the course I leaned
into the video crew at Orange and
rethink because I didn't have a video
crew and we did a revenue share of that
first course that I produced and I just
went to Freelancers and people who
really had
um
the expertise in areas I didn't because
I knew what I could bring I could bring
the audience to the product and I could
bring the content to the audience and
that was sort of my Lane in the same way
you know I used to be in radio 100 years
ago but uh when I launched the podcast
part of what was really enticing to me
is oh I was really picky about the music
really picky and I still am but I'm like
I could edit this myself and I chose not
to because we have a guy Toby Lyles he's
done all of our podcasts for all these
years it's fantastic never met him in
real life chatted with him a bunch but
um he's done all of that because I knew
my unique contribution was going to be
to get top level guests and to ask great
questions and host the show well that
that's my Lane I'm going to stick to it
but I think if you were you know tech
savvy the the thing is eventually I mean
I imagine you don't do a lot of editing
anymore do you Sean yeah and to that
point
I did pull off some online courses
mainly I created a YouTube for churches
course back when I wrote my own ebook I
still had an editor in the church and
some other things hustling with friends
kind of assistants Freelancers uploading
some videos but as soon as we entered
this era and those early days Heather
Taurus jumped on uh the bus and was the
equivalent of I think your two
assistants someone helping upload the
videos into the course send out emails
get the it members area organized all
that kind of stuff and to your point of
video editing I don't edit video anymore
that was kind of one of my core not only
do I teach video editing but I also was
a video editor so definitely for the
first even year year and a half of
business once think media was a little
more sophisticated I was editing video
and I think that's the point and we all
have friends and we all have different
strengths and we all have different
weaknesses and the other thing to
realize too is your first product should
be really good but it doesn't have to be
your final product
um our courses have gotten better and
better over the years and I mean one of
them we shot in lockdown right so it was
my son coming in on my iPhone to record
a course now we replaced that one with
another course down the road but yeah
you can you can get started pretty
humbly but what you have to make sure is
that the value that the user gets out of
the course and that's why I'm a big guy
for workbooks and application guides the
value is always it's like in a can of
paint right the value of the can of
paint is in the application if I have
five cans of paint in my basement does
nothing doesn't help anybody if I apply
it to a wall I got value out of that so
I want and that's why the refund rate is
so low that's why people buy the
products again and again because they
got so much value out of it if it's just
helpful information that you forget by
dinner nobody's coming back so you've
got to figure out how do I make this
stick in the end user's life that's very
powerful and I've learned that
at the end of the day if your online
course can get the person who's going to
purchase it a result then that's that's
the bottom line Andy Stanley you know
simplify down with the bottom line I
didn't have a YouTube channel set up
with cover art and thumbnails and I
didn't know how to title the videos and
now I do and if I got a video from not
having a video to having a video great
if I got from calendars chaotic to
calendar is not chaotic and I've
regained some hours and some peace of
mind and my anxieties noticeably be
lower great and I like that you didn't
just call it a workbook but you call it
an application guide and the campaign
analogy is so powerful because an online
course unopened and unutilized
um is not bringing transformation it not
only needs to be consumed but it needs
to be applied and so by actually
thinking about the application guide and
so many nuggets this was obviously a
very
packed mini master class as much as we
get back into you know a 50-minute
conversation
um but I really appreciate your very
prolific already with this there was so
many incredible nuggets in this process
um and so I recommend if you're
listening to this to re-listen to it to
pull out some of those details and I
like the grace that you gave us
um at the think media podcast of give
yourself a long runway in today's world
we just feel so much pressure so much
comparison on social media we never know
people's process but we see this person
oh man they're launching something or
they're doing that or they're doing that
and I still have an idea and it's and I
love what you've learned about
simmer you know let it simmer organize
it and what I respect the most is also
that you just care so deeply about the
end user getting a result and you care
deeply about spending the time refining
the idea I do think too many people are
rushing content to Market or they're
rushing content that's okay but it's not
great and that also is why people stay
stuck cream Rises to the top no matter
how many cups of coffee you pour but it
takes time to develop that cream it has
to you have to let it Brew you have to
let that simmer and and your uh the
intentionality you put in to build out
those incredibly poignant phrases it
probably encourages us listening to this
of realizing that took a five hour bike
ride for you to ultimately write a
sentence but then that sentence is
something that can live in live on and
impact people for weeks months years to
come eventually find its way into a book
into version 3.0 and you've built out
this incredible Empire following these
tips so I really appreciate you sharing
this can I have one more tip too you
know I was thinking about this this week
and you you helped me connect a few dots
because
uh if you give yourself a long Runway so
you don't have a long Runway okay do a
reel okay that doesn't that that reel
isn't gonna live two years from now it's
not a blog post isn't going to live two
years from now like like you know a
quick short isn't gonna live two years
from now probably so that's where you do
your experimenting that's where you do
your quick thinking but I really started
giving myself I've been communicating
for 30 years
I have been giving myself a longer
Runway only for about 12 or 13. and that
was in large measure because I met
people like Andy Stanley and and Jeff
Henderson and I started to write my
sermons and then later the content I do
now way ahead of time and I started
taking notes and sometimes I'll work for
a year on a piece of content before it
sees the light of day maybe doing a
quick little snippet here or a snippet
there just to test it
but what happens if you give yourself a
long Runway
is your ideas get better and better like
I was I was literally just thinking
about this now
um
some of the phrases I still use today
I've developed 12 or 13 years ago after
I gave myself a long Runway so one
that's popping to mind right now the
difference between love and lust
thought about that a lot you know what
it is now maybe it's more complicated
than this but if you want it in a simple
phrase lust takes love gives
if you're lusting after somebody
you want something from that person and
you don't care about that person when
you're finished with that person if you
love someone you want something for that
person not something from that person so
I first preached that maybe 10 12 years
ago
but it sticks and I could because I did
the hard work and that took a long time
to figure out but now that's become a
life principle if I find myself in a
place where I'm lusting it's like oh
yeah you just want to take from that
person you don't want to give to that
person that's not love that's lust and
the same is true for your audience right
you can be like I want to take from you
I don't want to give to you so that's a
handle that took me
a while to develop but it's standing up
more than a decade later so if you give
yourself a long Runway your chance of
running into ideas that you will still
be sharing and marketing like Patrick
lynchione the five dysfunctions of a
team a book's almost 20 years old he's
still talking about it because he gave
himself a long Runway to write it the
five love languages Gary Chapman wrote
that almost 30 years ago and it sells
more copies every year and I've run into
Gary Chapman at conferences and he says
it sells more copies every year he's
still talking about it because he really
put some thought into those five love
languages now they've been tested by
tens of millions of people and they
stand up that thing that you thought
about yesterday that you want to turn to
a course tomorrow probably is not going
to stand up 25 years from now but if you
give yourself a little extra time give
yourself a long Runway you're going to
produce better idea is and it's not that
the Nugget isn't there it's just not
developed enough to stand the test of
time and help thousands or millions of
people wow this was some brilliant death
carry I really appreciate that and it
and and you have the credibility to
prove it again this else inspires me
because I do want I want to create less
better
yeah and YouTube Secrets written in 2018
it's easy as a creative to want to move
on and do something else do the next
thing we have a million ideas even the
commitment to doing the second edition
was also taking the same thing and going
deeper and deeper and what I've found is
by sticking on that core message going
even deeper it's just made it more rich
and more sticky I'm learning so much and
I took pages of notes during this entire
conversation
um and I want to have great ideas that
stick and then ultimately your framework
of of putting kind of summing it all
together that in our best case scenario
as course creators and as content
creators that want to hit our financial
goals and and build Financial Freedom
and figure out how to monetize and maybe
go part-time go full time that that is
what we want but we don't want to take
from our audience we don't want to have
this coming from a place of lust and
just trying to get too many people again
they slap together a half-hearted rush
not thought through online course just
try to sell it build no Brand Build no
connection maybe have that terrible
refund rate but just try to get whatever
extract whatever they can get and then
just as opposed to Love Takes love
serves love gives and so if you're
coming from a place of love with your
online course putting all of this
painstaking work and margin and time and
thought and and what's also amazing just
like your book and an online course is
you've theoretically taken 50 100 200
500 hours and you've condensed it into
five hours or 500 hours and you've
condensed it into five modules
to a thousand hours and you've condensed
it into
180 Pages you know 10 000 hours and
you've condensed it into and and we
encourage people on YouTube to do that
as well that some of the best YouTubers
I was just with Andre dick personal
finance YouTuber he basically gets one
two three great videos out a week but in
a video takes about 10 to 20 to 25 hours
of reading and studying
and he can he takes 20 hours of reading
and studying and puts it into six
minutes
it's that refinement it's that
consolidation it's the fact that and and
the reason he's doing so well is because
that was not easy that was painful but
now the viewer gets to benefit from that
compression of time and the heavy
lifting he's done putting that in for
them well listen I know you've got uh
another show uh another things on your
calendar please shout out I know people
definitely got to check out your podcast
one of my favorite leadership podcasts
I'm always checking uh in to see what
topics you have a regular listener
myself at your best one of my favorite
books you've written we're gonna link up
um that book as well as your podcast in
the show notes but please re-articulate
anything you want to mention and how
people can connect with you and follow
you yeah you can find what I do on Kerry
newhof.com on Insta I'm at Kerry newhoff
and then you can check out the art of
leadership academy we are having a lot
of fun in there that's particularly for
church leaders so it's not for everybody
or if you're a faith-minded business
leader who cares about the church you
might have some fun in there as well but
it's been really great Sean thank you so
much I don't get a chance to talk about
this rarely if ever so it was a lot of
fun for me thank you appreciate you
Carrie thanks for coming on
[Music]
I am so grateful for Carrie new off and
all of the value that he added in this
episode and if you're new to the think
media podcast I want to recommend
checking out some of the past episodes
with Carrie he always delivers massive
value his book at your best was one of
the most profound impactful books for
myself in the think media team and
there's some really powerful episodes in
our library that I know you'll love with
Carrie now I also want to remind you
that coming up soon is our free five-day
YouTube challenge as Carrie was talking
about creating and marketing an online
course one of the things I've learned is
that YouTube is one of the best
platforms for course creators so whether
you already have a YouTube channel and
you're thinking about doing a course or
whether you already have a course that
you're improving but you want to Market
it more effectively when I've hung out
with Brands like teachable or thinkific
or kajabi at different events that I
speak out they all say that their most
successful students these course
creation platforms they say they're more
most successful students are active on
YouTube and are investing a lot of
energy in YouTube so the punch line is
that the combination between YouTube
content and creating and selling online
courses is a power combo and this is
where our five-day YouTube challenge
comes in if you want to jump start your
channel if you want to start a channel
from scratch if you want to learn about
the new trends and the latest things
working on YouTube right now you don't
want to miss this five-day immersive
event that is happening online it's
entirely free but you have to register
at
tube1kchallenge.com the URL is t-u-b-e
the number one the letter K and the word
challenge.com and of course that's in
the show notes as well if you're new to
the podcast and you're not subscribed
subscribe wherever you listen whether on
audio or whether you watch on our think
media podcast YouTube channel and it
means the world to myself and the think
media team when you hit the like button
or rate and review the podcast or leave
a comment with feedback or questions
about topics you'd love covered in
future episodes well hey I love and
respect you so much for just being a
part of our community my name is Sean
Cannell rhymes with YouTube channel and
I can't wait to connect with you in a
future episode of the think media
podcast take care